in each of the provence partie distribute
as already from situation
the situation in the dash so verbal
disarmament he now separated the
value commission note so the years
reduced interisti to zion alien
normandy latinos do it or regulate
mentor the relation in the disco
nobody there participation  the pony's
bullish scenario the lotito lihsa
publications processor verbal
teleportation students bio-quality and
presentations commission their
conferences commission information in
the commission the only portion the
lega north the ski mountains regula mader
combination ronny wiele in the
plenary debate rebels now already have a
school policy and now revised  the
two assona bastion in a
combination therapy president
turkish anger about the guests the
applications of the labradoodle jane
seymour matthias timoshenkos is the
way for the ref to document segment
gisela tivi durante christa thorner has
a great disposition interest gate in
front  the crisis the corridor
relation to the resolutions of the
presentation in clinics come the china
libero schumann and content organist
medication modification of the ego study
destination accurate prevention of the
chorona buseck with the china costa rica
is a prima you without the photos you are
the regulations separation is he  is
and party already location uri the
gst fee gates and radionuclides in
trilateral commission competent
controller criticize if your supply
the testers
position the industry through adaudience story as a financial
risk again the shame still a nice
cinema carola kroczek balcony or cat ii he
sees less over it  the guests the industry
brother james jolie situations
is elementary zion clinic foremny tour
medicine only the apa rollo rivoli
connection guests presenter vento contra
costa rica is a priori want
the rational rcg telecommunications it
and geopolitical the founding of
the soko corinna figures the
progn  ostiker the projector definitely the
ordination the underground 30
euros the on the internet the presentation euros the guests the situation of the game separate
this served reputation is the tribute
to the version information relative to
all distribution in the reputation is
a second behind the proclamation the
gene expression option commission
ambitious motive is already
proposition information electronic cash
and the postage marches as in forums prime
minister gunnar prokop because the
reaction of the opposition in the consilium
in our city which is presented at the
moment it is relatively large
it is usually an intel atom
submarines music and  she the apa the deed for
the generations concilio the commission
presentations of the programs has the
vita the president dsk like cordonier
political character
dear Mr
it's a pleasure to be able to
address the plenary session of the european parliament at the beginning of the german presidency
like most of
you, i missed the direct encounters
with people, the face-
to-face talks and for me
this is the first trip abroad after the
outbreak of the pandemic and you  leads me
consciously and with complete conviction
to the heart of
european democracy in these times when the
european union wants to survive this crisis stronger
in these times the
european parliament is needed the tasks ahead of
us are enormous and they require
enormous efforts they need
a parliamentary  debate
you need political mediation you
need cultural translations into the
different countries and regions and
that is why you are needed and it is therefore
a special honor for me to present the
priorities of the german
council presidency to you
today we are five topics at this time
particularly important our fundamental rights
cohesion climate protection
digitization and europe's
responsibility in the world these five
issues are important because we
have to change europe sustainably because who
want to protect and preserve
europe only then will europe be sovereign and responsible in a
rapidly changing global order
can and should take on their own role
is aware that my visit today is
taking place against the background of the greatest test in the history of the european union the
global corona virus pandemic
has also hit people hard and relentlessly in europe
we have over 100,000 deaths in europe alone
to mourn many
due to the strict rules, citizens were
not even able to say goodbye to loved ones in the last
hour.
this must not be forgotten,
despite all the effort for a new beginning and
all the commitment to economic
recovery, the mourning  the dead the
pain of the impossible farewells
this will be with us for a long time to come our
economy has been and will be
badly shaken across europe millions of
employees have lost their jobs
in
addition to concerns about
health and the health of
families, for many
citizens this is also the  fear for their
economic existence
they all need our
joint support now
to talk about the chains of infection
the most elementary
basic rights had to be temporarily restricted
that was a very high price because
generations in europe fought hard for these basic rights
human and civil rights are the
most valuable asset  that we have in europe
and they may only be restricted for very important
reasons and only for a very
short time a pandemic must never be used as an
excuse to undermine democratic
principles
every country in europe
remembers its own history differently  upheavals to
the different fighters for
freedom and the rule of law and
at the same time one of us exactly this
achievement of basic rights in europe
for me, as i have lived 35 years of my life
in a system of bondage
, the restriction of these rights
in the pandemic was a decision that was
extremely difficult for me  is
in this historical phase now
germany takes over the eu
council presidency
this task fills me with respect
but also with great passion because
i believe in europe i am convinced
of europe not only as a legacy of the
past but as hope and
visions for the future
europe is not only  something that was
handed over to us something fateful
that obliges us but europe is
something living that we can shape and
change
europe does not take away from us any
opportunities for action but in a
globalized world europe gives us
some only with europe we can not without
re convictions and
freedoms and for this
we need this more than ever the
orientation towards fundamental rights
at the same time more than ever mutual
support and community
cohesion in europe will only
remain europe if there are
innovative answers to the
challenges of climate change and
the  digitization exists and faces up to its
responsibility in the world these
are the major tasks
but i am confident think
of what europe has already passed in terms of tests and
conflicts think
of the failed constitution for
europe 15 years ago or the
economic and financial crises  about which
we argued hard or
think about the refugee movements
five years ago that was never easy
that always led to injuries but
even the most bitter crises
helped to
better understand the needs of each other
we learned together europ  a
survived all these crises because in the
end everyone was aware of what is essential
basic rights and
cohesion human beings and civil rights the
inviolability of human dignity
freedom for individual
personal political and
social development protection
against discrimination and disregard
last but not least equal rights the
equality is not only claimed should be realized
they form the ethical-political
foundation from the europa roth these are
the rights that apply to everyone
they do not apply to some more
others less
they do not always apply to some and
only sometimes
they apply to others  is the promise of
europe that we must guarantee that
citizens are really
free to live out their religious
beliefs, their cultural or
political beliefs, that
they are allowed to cling to their respective ideas of
happiness or the good life
en democracy
European democracy also thrives on
critical public debate a
democracy in which opposition voices are
undesirable a democracy in which
social or cultural or religious
diversity is undesirable is not. the
pandemic has shown us all too clearly
how precious
fundamental rights are  how elementary the
freedoms are that they guarantee
guard over the protection of these fundamental rights in
europe in the european union strong
institutions the european commission
the european court of justice and the
european parliament fundamental rights
they are the first thing that is
close to my heart during this presidency of the council to be
supported and supplemented  must that
through the second principle that europe
makes up our cohesion in europe
will only emerge stronger from this
crisis because we are willing
to find a common solution to all differences
because we are also willing to see the world through
the eyes of the other  showing respect and
understanding for the other perspective
europe will become stronger after the crisis
than before
if we strengthen common sense
no one can get through this crisis alone we are
all vulnerable
european solidarity is not
just a humane gesture but
a sustainable investment
european cohesion it is
something that is politically imperative but
something that will be worthwhile
and that is also the leitmotif of our
presidency of the council, making europe
strong again together
i will devote myself to this task with all my passion together
with the federal government
,
but i need you to do this for this community
spirit in the eu  Parliament needs to be protected
because they are the mediators of
mutual understanding that we
need in order to reach compromises.
They represent almost 450 million
citizens in 27 countries.
They are the translators of European
principles  mediating between brussels strasbourg
and their home regions they
not only communicate in 24 languages
but they live with this diversity
of perspectives and experiences
who if not you could explain
the attitude of other member states to the people in europe
and that is why
i ask you as a mediator and mediator
of cohesion  for your support
in these difficult times help
us to deepen mutual understanding
help us to
strengthen
europe's cohesion the top priority of the german presidency is for europe to
come out of the crisis united and stronger
but we don't just want to stabilize europe in the
short term that would be  too
little we want that gives hope in europe too
we want a europe that
faces the challenges of the present with self-confidence and courage
we want
a europe that is future-proof, that
innovatively and sustainably asserts its place in
the world we want a
new start for  europe
the german-french
initiative of mid-may also follows this conviction together with
french president
emanuel makro i have proposed a european structure
of 500 billion euros
i am pleased that the european
commission has included many aspects of these
german-french initiatives in its
proposal for a multi-annual  the financial framework
and the construction program are taken into account
on this basis, discussions are currently underway in the
european council under the leadership of
shells michelle our
common goal is to find an agreement as quickly as possible
because the depth
of the economic slump is a warning and
we must not lose any time
only the weakest would be among them  suffering
i very much hope that we can reach
an agreement this summer
that will require a lot of
willingness to compromise from all sides
, including you
the situation is extraordinary, indeed unique
in the history of the euro  european union
that is why germany also supported this
extraordinary and unique
effort of this magnitude
of 500 billion now
it will be important that we
also come to an agreement at european level
i am convinced that the social dimension
is just as important as the
economic one a socially and
economically just europe is
crucial  for democratic
cohesion it is the best recipe
against all those who want to
weaken our democracies and
call into question what we have in common for this reason
too, during our
council presidency we will focus our attention in particular on young
people and children they are
europe's future and from the  the crisis
has hit us particularly hard, which is
why we want to promote their development with a
european youth work agenda
and actively support them with a
strengthened youth guarantee on their way
into professional life,
and we mustn't be naïve  in many
member states, the opponents of europe are
just waiting to abuse the crisis for their own ends
, we must now show all those where the
added value of cooperation in the
european union lies, we must
show that the return to
nationalism
means less control, not more that only joint
action than  europe protects and strengthens
it is therefore right and important that
the regions particularly affected by the crisis
and above all the people
who live there can count on our
solidarity it is in our very own
interest but at the same time this
always means that the
effort is now  for the good of all
necessary is not unilaterally burdening the
economically strong
member states unduly that each of
us is required to put ourselves in the position of the
other so also
consider what the individual member
states can and cannot
achieve economically, socially and politically  isch
and in all this i ask you today as a member of
the european parliament for your support i am convinced that everyone is ready to show extraordinary solidarity in this crisis germany it is the management of the pandemic and its
consequences that will stimulate our presidency
at the same time we must always also
continue to exist others
we have the major challenges of our time in
mind these are the 10 3 4 and 5 that
will matter for europe first of all
climate change about six months ago the president of
the eu commission ursula von
der leyen presented her climate protection program in this house
she has urgent words for you
directed and emphasized that europe
must act now if our planet
wants to remain viable
but i am convinced that a global
solution to climate change is only possible
if europe takes a pioneering role in
climate protection
the strategy for a green deal of the
european commission is therefore for
us  an important guideline with
your close support during the course of our council
presidency, we want to create the
transition to a carbon-neutral
economy and society to a
green economy with strong and
innovative companies an
economy that protects the natural
foundations of life and the
competitiveness of europe for
future generations and
strengthens it is important to me that we
legally establish europe's climate neutrality by 2050 and that's why
i welcome the
european commission's consideration as an
interim step to reduce emissions by
2030 to 50 to 55 percent
compared to 1990
in this perspective we will
also work on the european
climate protection law accompany another
major challenge and the fourth
point that is particularly important to us during our us
presidency
is the digital change
he as well as climate protection requires
that we change our way of life and
economy  changing communities sustainably
that triggers fear in many people fear of
losing familiar
fear of the pace of change and
that is understandable but let
me say very clearly the commitment
to digitization for
climate protection does not mean that we
give up everything established and  so that the
jobs of millions of
europeans are jeopardized on
the contrary, it is about a
necessary change in our society
that will offer more protection and more sustainability in the long term
, because
in the past few weeks and months in particular,
europe's digital dependency
on third countries has become clear to us
again  many of us have undoubtedly noticed in the
course of our daily digital
communication,
be it in technology or in
services,
it is important that europe digitally
changes, especially in the
key areas of artificial
intelligence and quantum computing, but
also in a  we want to move forward with the construction of a
trustworthy and secure
digital infrastructure
, but effective
protection of our democracies against cyber
threats and information campaigns is also crucial,
because a democracy needs a
public space in which knowledge and
information can be shared, in
which citizens can
exchange information and communicate about
it  how you want to live
we love it right now with lies and
disinformation the
pandemic cannot be fought any more than with hate
and agitation denying the facts populism
is shown its limits in a
democracy
in a democracy it needs truth
and transparency that is what distinguishes europe
and what makes it so  will germany
stand up for its council presidency
and fifthly, for europe's responsibility
in a globalized world a look
at the map shows, in addition to
great britain and the western
balkans, europe at its external borders is
r  ussland belarus
ukraine turkey
syria lebanon jordan israel egypt libya tunisia
algeria morocco surrounded
at the same time we live in a time of
global upheaval in which the fields of
force are shifting and europe is
more on its own despite the integration of many member states into the transatlantic alliance
can and must decide for themselves
who europe wants to be in this rapidly
changing world order
it is more important than ever whether we
are serious about europe whether we want a
europe that preserves its freedom
and identity even in times of
globalization
in this situation  if there is
a need for a strong european
foreign and security policy
, the united kingdom is and will remain an important partner in this
regard shaping
the future relationship will be a
major concern for us in the coming six months
the progress made in the negotiations
so far, to say the
least, about  obviously we have
agreed with great britain
to speed up these negotiations in order to
conclude an agreement in the autumn that would
then have to be ratified by the end of the year
i will continue to campaign for a good
solution
but we should also make provisions for the
event that an agreement does not
come about after all  come on during our
presidency, we should do everything we can
to make progress in three other
foreign policy areas, firstly at the accession conference,
at least with north macedonia and
possibly also with albania, an
important step on the way to
giving the states of the western balkans the prospect of accession
, and
secondly for our relationship  with our
neighboring continent africa and the
african union, which we want to deepen in a
future-oriented manner at the eu-africa summit
,
this also includes questions of
our migration cooperation,
there are more people fleeing
than ever before
because of this  do we have a special
responsibility to move forward with you for a
central issue in europe, such as asylum and
migration policy?
that is a question that requires a lot of political
sensitivity, but we
must not look the other way, we must face
this humanitarian and
political task together
and, last but not least, our
strategic  relations with
china are characterized by close
trade-political ties but
also very different
socio-political
ideas, first of all in the protection of
human rights and the rule of
law and even if the eu-
china summit in september unfortunately cannot
take place, we want to continue the open
dialogue with china
during the
during the german council presidency, we also
want to continue our reflections on whether or not we want to stick to the principle of unanimity
in questions of foreign and
security policy
and what lessons europe can learn from
the  corona virus crisis is supposed
to happen, for example with a view to how
europe’s sovereignty in the
health
sector could be strengthened, we should also have this debate as part of
a conference on the future of
europe, which was proposed by the european
commission last
year and to which you
have many ideas with your resolution  have developed
i advocate a conference that concentrates
on a few topics with
concrete results and
brings citizens from and in
different member
states together for discussion
i already spoke to the president
of the european parliament david
sorry about this today mr president mrs
commission president meine  Ladies and
gentlemen, if we want Europe, then
what I spoke about today is needed, then
we need fundamental rights and
cohesion, then we need answers
to climate change and
digitization, then Europe needs
responsibility in the world  we have to make
europe greener, digital and therefore more
innovative and
competitive because europe should internationally
stand for a legal order and
europe should internationally stand for innovation
and sustainability
that is the vision for europe let
me close with a personal thought
i am a music lover and all that  it
gives me great pleasure that we and our council presidency have a very
special anniversary in december
if the composer of the european anthem ludwig van beethoven would have been
250 years
old this ninth symphony
is still fulfilling and always new
every time i listen to it i discover something different
in  the music that hits and
impresses me and europe too it
can always be rediscovered and it
always impresses me and so let
me end today with the wish that the
message of this music, the idea of
brotherhood and unity, guides us in europe which message could
pass  be different than this, that this
europe is capable of great things if we
stand by each other and stick together,
thank you very much m graziella president of the commission von
der leyen president
[music]
grazie president mrs federal chancellor
novembers we look forward to the
german council presidency council presidencies
you ca
n’t choose  instead, they are distributed according to
a set
pattern and germany has
in fact fallen into a phase
that could not be more challenging and
the expectations of the german
council presidency are high i know it
is pressing but that is also something
nice
because you show it too  dare to do
something, ladies and gentlemen, the
crown crisis calls many things into question,
socially and economically, including
our own, of course,
the way we see ourselves and the
way we see ourselves in relation to
others and the whole thing is taking
place in front of a backdrop of a  world in which
the ha  As the existing
structures continue to dissolve,
we think differently and new
about the value of solidarity
and community triggered by the corona crisis. We
think new and different about the great
value that our common Europe has,
which has to be worked out anew every day
and yes it was  at the beginning so that many
looked inward at the small
and not enough at the big and the
common but then we pulled ourselves
together and when he saw with
european eyes and
felt again with a european heart and
madam chancellor also thanks to the
contribution germany in  In the past few
weeks, this spirit of
responsibility for the whole thing has been back in
Europe. In
the face of this crisis, we are now
hearing words from all corners of the compass on our
continent and
we see actions that give reason to hope
that we can do it together,
which is good for Europe  that's good
for us too, when I hear that, I know
this is again the sound of europe that
wants to belong to
and this rediscovered spirit of
responsibility for the whole that is not a
bad companion when you are in the
starting blocks of a council presidency
that will point the way for the
future of our union
the extraordinary
almost 600,000 live shows contraction
rebound
button  in memories a samovar member
state stewart circle to george
skywalker tinc-news an
baumen jason young people living home and
research for job from june thiessen
president and drop in public investment
so that public programs and public
infrastructure civil a from the mini to
visit the experience
at the  does not have to be supported
public investment beginning of the
people the jobs
first choice
solidarity
in the individual expectations and
projections
a my second ist
do what the f e budget next generation
[applause]
[music]
fdp president maximum respect problem
[applause]
together  make
grazie graziella presidents of  the
leyen president your political and we
want to remain free
denzler merkel president von der leyen president of
the soli college is name is
francesco this julia doctor of
home remedies in bergamo
dr